All of Maga is turning their back on
Trump and people are defending the Pope.
Trump was going to to be set up as a
false Antichrist. I'm going to show you
where I started talking about this a
year ago. Donald Trump actually started
going off on all his people, like his
Maga crew, Candace Owens, Alex Jones,
Tucker Carlson, Megan Kelly, and he just
started blasting on them and now they're
turning on him because they're saying,
"Why are you even in this war? Like what
why can't we just have peace?" And so
you see Candace Owens, man, she used to
be all about some Trump. Now listen to
the what she's saying now. Trump is very
clearly under demonic influence. I think
Paula White probably put a spell on him
of some sort.
>> [music]
>> I mean, he is surrounded by ironically
the very thing that he accuses me and
Megan and Tucker of being because we're
calling for peace. Isn't that crazy? So
she just said that
she thinks he's under a demonic
influence. And then here's Tucker
Carlson, you know, these guys are buds.
And listen to what he just said. This
isn't so much
a couple of memes, these are icons, this
is iconography. These are attempts to
send a statement about faith. What
statement is the president sending?
Well, not a coherent one. Doesn't
actually add up to a theology, it's
mockery. He's mocking Jesus, he's making
fun of Christianity. The central figure
of the religion is being held up for
mockery. And his description of how this
got out is itself mockery, mockery of
the idea of truth. One day he says,
"Yeah, I did it." Next day he says, "No,
I didn't do it." Both are in video. It's
not really a lie, it's more than a lie,
it's bigger than a lie. It's an attack
not just on a specific set of facts,
it's an attack on the idea that there
are facts. It's an attack on truth,
openly. These are the loudest voices in
our world today, so when they say
something, people listen. And they're
starting to say, "Trump's demonically
possessed. Trump's the Antichrist. He's
blasphemous. We need to turn against
him." And people are starting to put the
pieces together and I think more and
more people are going to start calling
him out as the Antichrist. And when he's
identified as the Antichrist, the stage
is being set for Satan to appear as the
cosmic Christ, a supernatural being
who's going to put an end to what Trump
is doing, whether that's to put an end
to Trump or his system or whatever. But
then he's going to unroll this false
system of peace and safety. Satan right
now is setting up the false Antichrist
and it's Trump.
You think Trump
is the